good morning and welcome to the
continuing series of hearings on the
retained bail bills we have if you would
join me in Rising for the Pledge of
begin the flag the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation
all with that I believe we have a
presentation this morning um and if you
would please come to the mic and
introduce yourself and what we'll be
hearing morning Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm going to have the
folks from SAS Institute come up here
and introduce themselves uh but my name
is Jonathan M and I'm with deur and
preol um so while they introduce
themselves I'll also be handing out a
presentation for you all as
well if you could just tell us who they
are and what they what they're here for
uh so they'll be able to explain more
but they're primarily a data analytics
uh specializing in data analytics and
they have uh previously done work in
North Carolina doing a criminal justice
uh tracking system and are here to
present and answer any questions uh you
all might have in you know do in uh
implementing a similar system here
thank
you
good morning good morning my name is
manura Deus I'm with SAS Institute I
thank you for having us today um I am as
John had mentioned we are part of a
we're actually a company a software
analytics company and I am um the
account manager that supports all of our
state and local government agen es in
you good morning everyone my name is
John Caris I'm a principal industry
consultant with SAS happy to be here
today and my role is to help really
government agencies across the country
um on leveraging data and analytics to
improve Services outcomes um and really
decisions so happy to be here today look
forward to the
conversation hi good morning every
everyone my name is Jake yokul I manage
our state and local government practice
for the Northeast um my team what we do
is we help departments States leverage
their data for some of their more
strategic initiatives um and embed
different data and analytic strategies
into those initiatives so thank you for
presentation all right I have to say
this is my first time talking into Mike
so thank you um so we are as I had said
we represent SAS Institute and probably
many of you don't know who SAS is SAS is
a company that is headquartered out of
North Carolina Carri specifically car
North Carolina and I've been working for
them for about seven years I'm
originally from New England actually and
came from Boston and then moved to North
Carolina for various reasons our company
um I'm going to start from the beginning
and say that our company started out in
as a project in the late 1960s when a
number of different universities came
together to look at a system a
statistical and a software package to be
able to look at agriculture data and
that data had they wanted to analyze was
to identify where they can maximize crop
yields as a result of that which was
funded by the NIH they developed a
system called the statistical analysis
system which is SAS that system analyzes
billions and billions and rows of data
in a sec in in many seconds and it helps
change the way we work and the way
people
live and since
1976 our founder and CEO today Dr
Goodnight developed this system now is
in all over the world in many many
different countries and because of that
we're able to work in faster ways in
ways that we are we're able to save
lives and able to be more
efficient because of our roots in the
education system and in government SAS
is a leader a leader in artificial
intelligence and data analytics and as
Jonathan had said earlier that is where
our strengths are is being able to
analyze data from disperate sources in
ways that no other software company can
really do and since over the last five
decades we've been able to demonstrate
that what we wanted to to share with
with you today is a little bit about
what we've done in the state agencies
we're in about 134 countries around the
world we're in about 1600 different
departments and agencies and bureaus in
the world and we're also in recognized
in many different areas in terms of um
Finance in health care in
pharmaceutical but again our foundation
in the state so we are actually in New
Hampshire we have a number of different
agencies that we serve um we serve in
hospitals we serve in the education
systems we also serve in many of the
different agencies here and so I'd like
to turn it over to Jake to kind of talk
through um some of the things that we've
done in the Northeast he oversees many
of those um agencies that we are that
are using SAS and I think if you look at
the um presentation deck there is we
serve eight every eight different
pillars and I'll turn it over to Jake to
kind of describe
that thank you
manura so we recognize that agencies and
States today have more data than they've
ever had um data that exist in different
silos from different systems that we've
invested in over the past several years
the data is out there um what SAS does
is help those States those agencies use
that data in ways to make better
decisions um how do you our our systems
help the agencies help States be able to
bring that data together to make those
decisions make those policy decisions um
resource
allocations that they're trying to do
based on what the data is saying based
by what that evidence is pointing
towards um few examples I I want to call
out from across the Northeast um you
know we do a lot of work in the public
safety realm um one of the states that
that we're working with um with their
Fusion Center operations right to help
them um contribute data and analyze data
from you know the a local perspective
State perspective and then also
reporting that up to a federal uh the
federal um government as well right then
in addition to that we're we're working
with a different state with um there's
1600 Troopers that are using our
software every day um touching the
software every single day um and it's
pulled to the the software is pulled
together all their data from across
Corrections uh from across Public Safety
and uh Homeland Security right and
there's they they that state has
actually developed a um data sharing
Network across those agencies as well
which we're supporting um and then in
the public health space again there's we
recognize that there's also an overlap
between public health and Public Safety
um and we are supporting bring get
bringing together in a different state
different agency data from Department of
Health from Public Safety to be able to
analyze um impacts of different
different policies different resource
allocations um again based on what the
data is saying today so the reason we're
here today is to talk more specifically
about a project in North Carolina that
is very um very relevant to some of the
the conversations around data sharing as
it relates to Public Safety um and I
will turn it over to John to talk more
specifically about
that
thanks Jake um can everyone hear me okay
okay good so uh you guys have in your
handouts and so I feel like I'm going to
be a teacher and say go to the next page
and here's what you're seeing um but I
think that's going to be the easiest
thing to do so what I'm going to walk
through is a little bit more of my
background and and why am I here not
just from a SAS perspective but from a
experienc perspective um and then you
know walk through kind of what data is
in this system which is really the
relevant components of what you probably
are looking for what data have you
integrated how have you surface that
data um tell me about the roles and how
people use
it some what I we call screenshots from
the system um and then show some of the
what makes up some of the reports that
might be really important like pre-trial
service report and those type of things
um so I'm going to walk through it I
know it's going to be um kind of like an
eye chart on these uh on on what you
have but I think it will I'll I'll walk
through and describe it I think in a way
that will all make sense and then of
course um we're we're all open to
discussions and question of course as at
the direction of the of the chair so
again happy to be here John carelles um
and again I described my role as a a
principal industry consultant and and
you know I came from uh the state of
North Carolina um I spent over 25 years
with the state of North Carolina um the
last seven or eight of those years I was
the deputy State Co and chief data
officer and within that
organization uh there was something
called uh a really uh amazing group
called the government data analytics
Center or GAC for short and and as I
described my role at SAS is you know uh
integrating data um improving uh you
know outcomes and and and trying to gain
intelligence from from from the data to
improve Services gdac did the same thing
gdac worked across an Enterprise um 17
agencies in in the state were
contributing data which is essentially
all the agencies contri contributing
data and receiving some type of analytic
benefit back in their operations it's
not data and analytics for analytics
sake it's to do something with to make a
decision right so data doesn't help
unless you use it and and you use it in
a way that's you know clear about what
you're going to do with it recognizing
privacy recognizing security is of
utmost importance
and then you know handle that data
responsibly so the the the solution I'm
going to talk about today and this gets
a little confusing for me because I was
a state employee for over 25 years and
I'm on the vendor side I've been here
about 18 months but this system was
under my leadership in North Carolina so
if I get confusing sometimes I talk
about it like I'm still administering
the system and sometimes I talk about it
like a vendor so please put those
together and bear with me but uh let's
talk a little bit about what CJ leads is
um and that stands for the criminal
justice law enforcement automated data
services and so this
solution uh really provides uh a wealth
of data in one place to present a single
view of an offender a comprehensive
trusted single view of an offender and I
may go into some of the data components
but that that's of utmost importance um
but how this system came to be was
unfortunately through a lot of really
good ideas and solutions come from
tragedies in government that we have to
address in government so when you think
about um you know a lot of these these
Solutions that's how they came to be so
in North Carolina we had two very
high-profile murders um uh from two
students at are Flagship universities
which are U University of North Carolina
and Duke University and these two um
students were murdered by two
individuals that were known that that
were on probation but because the data
wasn't off connected you know they you
were only seeing a part of the picture
when they showed up in court should they
have been on the streets because there
was additional charges while they're on
probation whatnot now I'm not going to
say the outcomes would have been
different but there might have been
different opportunities to intervene
with those outcomes so uh similar uh uh
so really the legislature um and really
all of State wanted to understand what
we could have done better from a state
perspective from a local perspective
just across the board and uh what we
really understood was from a data
perspective our Criminal Justice System
it absolutely was not a
system uh from a data perspective right
so it was a bunch of silos um you know
the data was all available that was
probably needed it's just it's it's in
their like Silo um organizations so what
came of that was trying to address that
problem by developing that single view
of an offender
by integrating the data more fully and
also trying to break down those it
barriers right and again it's it's the
data is there it's sitting in a in a
silo it's not being leveraged because
you know and you could access these
systems if you go to all of them and
then you're you're you're burdening uh
yourself with the time it takes you need
to move on to maybe another another uh
search I another the problem those type
of things so it's about efficiencies so
you'll see a slide that kind of
highlight CJ leads or some quotes on it
I'm not going to go through the whole
slide but really the purpose was the
results really were um uh to to increase
Public Safety by having this information
um and and that's both those that the
the criminal justice organizations were
serving as well as increasing the safety
for the criminal justice professionals
and then also you know to create those
efficiencies right so if we could take
10 to 15 minutes off of searching that's
real money that's general fund
Appropriations or that's you know local
Appropriations that you know create
those efficiencies so you'll see some
metrics where the state's reporting
today are last year 18.6 million just in
efficiencies and that's looking at all
the time it takes to what would have
taken to go through all those systems
and having a centralized uh view of that
offender you know just saves that time
as well as increases uh Public Safety so
that's where it came to be um another
how it also came to be and I mentioned
the the the unfortunately the
high-profile murders um and the All
State approach the legislature also you
know put GAC uh uh on on course to say
uh to develop a pilot program to
actually integrate criminal justice data
get all the partners in the room uh
provide some funding to get it going and
provide authority to get it going uh
because on these type of Ventures
there's a couple things that are always
needed accountability and authority and
those things were granted and then quick
check-ins to check on progress and to
remove barriers as you all can imagine
um being the committee you serve on um
you know data sensitive governance is
important and it's not just about
connecting data it's about Connecting
People connecting organizations and
breaking down some of those silos that
technical so I'm going to uh teaching
moment next
slide sorry uh Jake spoke to this and
manura spoke to kind of our portfolio
what number slide we on oh I'm on
integrated data it should be slide six
if we get the same numbers thank you
you're welcome thank you for asking um
so when we talk about integrated data
6.5 okay yeah that's
good so on the dat I'm not going to go
too much into this slide but as I
describe kind of what we're doing for
criminal justice I think when you start
looking at at government problems those
large government problems they're really
complex um and and sometimes governments
have focused on trying to solve them
from one agency's data perspective and
what I would say is the problems are
interconnected across state services and
those type of things never more apparent
than in criminal justice right so the
connectivity of those services
um you know are really important which
means the connectivity of the data is
really important um because you're
really looking at it from a perspective
of not just what one service is doing
but what's the collective impact of the
services and investment government's
making to improve or or inform a problem
so when we start talking about criminal
justice or any part of our portfolio a
lot of what we focus is on Enterprise
approaches Enterprise strategies
Enterprise delivery because that's
really where those Investments are
enhanced because the problems are are
are I'm not going to say solved but you
can come up with a better
approach so I'm going to dive deeper in
next slide into the the meat of this and
again I'm I'm just going to cover some
surface points from this system you know
I'm not trying to do a demo I'm not
trying to get too deep there's a lot
more functionality capability um in this
system but I'm going to try and
highlight the most important piece which
is the data piece and the accessibility
to that data so I'm going to walk
through some screenshots very quickly
and just kind of talk a little bit about
them but this slide seven where it says
CJ leads integrated data summary is
really uh the best slide in this deck
because it shows what data has been
integrated so you can see the data
that's been integrated courts warrants
um protective orders Corrections
probation DMV of course and other lure
data is included in the system many many
more um you know just looking at this
you probably realize the effort it takes
just to get people to contribute their
data and be able to receive benefit back
from that so this is really again the
software the analytics that's all
wonderful but the process and the
governance and those type of things
can't be ignored because you can't get
there without it so this is I think um
speaks Testaments Testament to um is a
testament to all the work that not just
GAC or you know me leading the
organization performed it's actually The
Testament of the work
of all these agencies to to to Really
bite into the same objective share that
that values and and and want to you know
work together to collectively solve
problems um the one thing I should also
say is CJ leads is used by over 25,000
criminal justice professionals today
it's probably closer to 26
27,000 700 agencies are participating in
this program and leveraging it so it's a
it's a pretty big effort
um with a lot of buyin um and it's m
very mature at this point um and it took
a little while to get there um as as
most things do most good things take a
while to get there um but again these
are folks using it every day um to to to
I'm not going to say to solve problems
to react to some situations etc etc so
slide eight says CJ leads critical
foundational
components and so I I'm going to be
talking about screenshots and the
technology and those type of things a
little bit not very deep but what I want
to address is you know technolog is
critical but but again I've already said
this but I want to say it again
developing sound processes um and
practices and support for the system you
know are also critical because you'll
never get to a technology unless you
address those so on the right hand side
you'll see some boxes access policy
security authentication user admin
training requirements system auditing
communication I'm going to talk a little
bit more about those because those are
foundational to anyone trying to do an
effort like this um so access policy so
when you think about this this is your
governance so from a governance
perspective there's there's a couple
different aspects of this one is those
that contribute data to the system and
that's addressing and identifying all
the privacy and and and you know sieges
and security concerns that may need to
be addressed um and making sure
everyone's comfortable in how the data
is going to be handled manag managed
protected and who's going to be using it
right so that's really critical to get
out of the blocks what's also critical
is you know organizations organiz those
700 organizations need to also know um
what they can do on their side so that
might be a local police department needs
to sign a policy and needs to review a
policy and and there needs to be
conversations to make sure they
understand how their um how their
officers can use the system similar with
the courts and those type of things so
very well documented um processes that
are followed policies that are updated
as they need to be as new data is added
as data is changed as we see you know
changes in the world that privacy
policies change we need to address those
and I I know I took a lot of time going
through that but I think we all know
those are very important things the
other is security and authentication and
and that's you know something you do
right so this isn't necessarily a policy
this is how do you protect that data and
making sure everyone's you know informed
and comfortable with that but it's also
about how you actually access the system
so this system is protected by
multiactor authentication so you know
it's two factors to be able to log in to
be able to um get gain access to the
data Etc um user Administration so this
is a state system but you know there's
it's it's deployed to those 700
organizations the state doesn't know
necessarily when a user from a police
Department comes and goes so being able
to deliver that delegated administrative
Authority back to the agencies to manage
and control their users and and to
create super admins that you know that
that are part of the system is real
important too otherwise it's just a
jumbled mess and making sure practices
are in place to do that the other is
training requirements right so if you're
going to use the system we want you to
know how to use the system right what
and so we have these practices access
policy those typ type of things but how
do you put that into practice right
we're not going to provide uh data to a
certain role that doesn't need to see
that data but at the end of the day we
don't want a court official um someone
that's you know determining bail those
type of things to not understand how to
use that system and and miss out on
intelligence that would have been
important for that next action right um
and then uh the system administ system
auditing so that's user system so
especially in this space you know we set
up from the day one an auditing
capability that is every click is
audited so what John carelles does in
the system who I search um all my
activity is auditable we uh the state
also publishes or puts back to whoever's
identified in the agency let's say it's
a local police department the chief of
police or Court official those type of
things we will provide back audit
reports on their users so they can see
hey is this kind of normal activity um
compared to other users in my
organization um and if if not they can
request deeper audits to say I want to
know what this individual's been doing
for however period of time to see if
they're using the data uh the system
appropriately so having those audit
capabilities to understand how folks are
using it holding them accountable as
well is is absolutely important to that
system and then I have communication and
communication is a across the board but
there's a couple things I want to
highlight about communication which is
we have so much data in this system
that's updated very frequently so when
we think about some of the data uploads
every night um or multiple times a day
some of it's real time and some of that
data is warrants that's real time
protective orders all those things DMV
um images those type of things it's real
time um information so that you can
react to and again some of it's updated
every night communicating to the users
so they can see when was this data last
updated um is important so in their
reports they can see the data I'm
looking at it when was it tagged it was
updated 5 minutes ago or was it updated
you know um is it real time and it's
literally current as of this second and
I say like real time like warrants um
warrants is real time is there a warrant
that we need to be aware of but then it
may not hit your criminal criminal
history until it loads that that night
into your criminal history right so it
uploads once a day but it's also real
time to tell you if there's an issue so
again it's a it's a it's a really um uh
you know all these factors all these
things really are uh have to be
addressed before even implementing you
know a technology solution um the next
slide slide nine is just again I'm not
going to cover much here but here are
some of the roles that access this and
each state may call different roles
differently magistrate May you know be
be setting bail in North Carolina um you
might have I think bail Commissioners um
and then you also have judges depending
on the offenses and those type of things
and charges excuse me that uh you know
that that may be looking at this but
what I wanted to clearly show here is
that there's roles and you fit into one
of these roles or you don't have access
to the system okay and the other thing
is when we start talking about this type
of data really any sensitive D data in
government you know I know the state of
North Carolina takes us approach I know
SAS takes this approach which is minimum
data necessary to do your job right so
we don't want to hold data back from
people that you know could really use it
to to you know do a better job at
delivering Services back to
organizations but data is risk right so
if you don't need it you don't have it
and that's the approach that that's
taken here and again um not trying to be
stingy we're just trying to be
responsible
okay next slide uh um which is slide 10
and this is just a a a kind of a
depiction this is the navigation menu
and I know it's really hard to read and
I'm not going to be going through this
because um we would be here till Friday
um which I'm happy to do um but I don't
think that's what you're looking for um
we'll be happy to don't feel rushed uh
we want to make sure we get all the all
the available information that may apply
to this excellent okay thank you uh Mr
chair um so on the navigation and the
menu it's really simple so so a couple
things I want to call out we'll put any
type of immediate news that folks need
to be aware of um we'll put back on
screen you know remember your access
policy and whatnot and then we get
provide simple navigation um I'm going
to transition and and go through some of
the actual screenshots but what I want
to also highlight is you're looking at
what the system would look like but this
even the screenshots are from a demo
system okay so we have a live demo
system that does not have any real data
in it it's all fictitious right it's
made up just for the purposes of
training and the purposes of
demonstration so when you see names um
that they're not real um I just want to
be clear on that um I'm going to
highlight kind of how the system would
work and how you would uh also um
interact with it um but what I really
want to get into show you the
comprehensive uh details of what's in
that system as well at a very high level
still
so next slide is slide 11 and I want to
uh kind of not so much tell a story but
discuss how someone might use this
system so if I do a search and I'm doing
a search on John Porter John Julian
Porter uh Jay Porter um what it's going
to return is and I'm just searching on
an individual's name there's DMV
searches there's partial name searches
there's you know other criteria that you
could search on on but the results are
the same it presents back the system
presents back who based on the
information you provided who is likely
the individual you're looking for and
then it will provide some other folks
that might be similar so that you can
make a determination do I have that
right person um because you may be
staring at this individual and now you
see a picture and it's like it's not
number one it's number
two it does and it also does um uh
things like uh um uh fuzzy matching and
then soundex which is how someone's name
sounds and and does the any resolution
around that so there's many factors I
mean obviously you can search on social
security number and those type of things
if you have it but there's many ways
into the system and part of that depends
on your role part of that depends on you
know what you're doing if you're pulling
someone over um and you have a license
plate you're that's your way into the
system to understand who you're dealing
with um but sometimes you may have start
with a with an ID you may start with
just them telling who them who who they
are um but recognizing at the time of
arrest uh not trying to be um snarky but
we have a lot of Donald Ducks and Santa
Claus at the time of arrest right so you
know you want to know kind of those
things too because even at the time of
arrest they may say they're Donald Duck
but they may say they live at 100 Main
Street that might be enough information
you know it's hard to consistently lie
right so they may provide a a sniff of
the right information for you to find
out who they are right so um hopefully
that makes sense the other thing that
that you're seeing is a bunch of red
letters and that's really important
because we put things in red that that
you need to react to so in red you'll
see these are warning warning icons or
Flags is what we call them and so
AWC which is approach with caution
that's the most immediate thing you need
to see and I know that's more particular
for law enforcement but still really
important and you'll see other red flags
going across John Julian Porter that are
also important and this isn't the nicest
individual in North Carolina if it was a
real person because there's a lot of
stuff going on here this person has has
orders for arrest they're a sex offender
they're habitual felling um they have
protected orders they have been involved
in Community Corrections they're gang
affiliated so on and so on so again this
is a little bit much but when you start
using this in the real world you'll see
maybe one or two flags that you need to
immediately think about address and
figure out how you're going to respond
to and and so that's the most critical
thing um so this is kind of that high
Lev view just determining who someone is
but it's still giving you enough
information to react to okay so I want
to put that out there but if you were to
click in to view more and that would be
on the next
slide and you know this is a
comprehensive summary but it's not a
detail
summary so as you click in again what
you see is red right I know it's a
little bit kind of a orangey red but
it's red um those are the things that
you need to think about address or
basically activity going on with this
individual that you need to be aware of
so you'll see a lot of other information
on here you can actually go through
things like past addresses and and
there's watch lists and other
capabilities on here but again I'm just
addressing I want to talk a little bit
about the the navigation and how you
drill even further um in this you know
getting this detailed information for
you to react to and respond to so in the
red you know you'll see what's going on
you can see sex offender you can see the
um been in prison and all these
different factors um but then you'll see
also um in the middle of the page that
this person has two pending um court
cases so if we wanted to click and you
can click on the left nav or you can
click right on that to understand what
are those two pen pending court cases
because that's really important um so if
you click on there if you go to the next
slide and again I apologize it's a
little hard to
read but at the very top you can see um
those two pending cases the county and
you can see that these this is for
traffic these court cases and there's
ability to scroll all the way to the
right there's a ton more information on
here now if there was uh disposed of
cases you would see all those I I think
on the previous page this is where it's
demo and we try and in training I know
with the state try and throw some
anomalies at folks to understand like
the previous page said I think there
were 62 disposed cases but when you come
to this page there's only two well
that's kind of for training purposes
what doesn't add up so if you see some
of those anomalies that's intentional
okay um but if you want to go a little
further sometimes it's about um those
details and if you go to the next slide
sometimes it's you know you want to
frame what you're looking at so you're
looking at data you're looking at tables
you're looking at information but
sometimes you want to see things on a
timeline like how how clustered were
these events this criminal history um
you know is this a real recent Trend or
was it you know 20 years ago where a lot
of this was so so again the looking at
the criminal history on a time
timeline's very helpful and if you were
to click on the icons on the timeline
you would get more details about that
event
um you can also um I've got the timeline
set up for basically year-over-year you
can actually go deeper and look at you
know briefer periods of time um because
that may be important to you as well um
in determining what your next move is
right your next action so I think having
the ability to look both at kind of this
this you know very heavy textual type of
information good but then to be able to
see that timeline's also helpful for
some instances and we've heard um from
our users and testimonials about both
have been really helpful so so um what I
want to just briefly um talk about um is
also some of the reporting so what I'm
not showing is all the different can
reports and or or I should say
predefined reports in the system that
users want to interact with so you know
I'm showing searches and how you can
dive deeper into the various um criminal
history and those type of things but
sometimes you just want show me the
information here's my person I'm I'm
looking at the offender now just produce
a report so I can actually just you know
look at it succinctly and and I can go
through what's important to me so one
example of this is that's been really
helpful for you know our folks that are
looking at you know uh bail and and
those type of things and conditions Etc
is been the pre-trial report and so this
is a report that again certain users can
go to they can run that report it's
audited what they're doing why they're
doing it and be able to return um
information and results and I'm showing
this a little bit differently because uh
if I showed you just kind of a report it
it doesn't make as much sense in a small
form factor um like the slide so what I
want to describe is all the information
that's contained in that pre-trial
report for an offender so this next
slide 16 shows pre-trial report in the
middle and I want to talk about and I'm
going to show more details on this but I
want to talk about some of what data is
being pulled back in to that report so
you have
convictions um and and that's obviously
important but the violent convictions
are called out separately because of how
important that is when thinking about um
if someone should be released while they
you know wait trial um probation um uh
you know uh unserved warrants um orders
for arrest uh pending cases and we we
heard a lot of feedback from our users
when this went live that you know they
may um they may be making
determinations without recognizing that
there's pending casing cases in other
counties um there's uh even if there are
cases in other counties um that they
they weren't aware that they didn't show
up right so there's a lot of factors
that go into it so having that
information here is important um failure
to appear of course I was covering that
as well so this is really what we heard
was um this was enough information
really good information for a
professional to be able to make a really
good um uh uh evidence-based judgment
okay so if you go to slide
17 um this is is not the prettiest
picture but I want to I wanted to unpack
that previous slide a little bit and and
again with data in here it actually
looks more messy so what I wanted to do
was is go through um you know those same
data that's coming into this pre-trial
report and provide what details of that
data come in so you can see what data is
in the convictions and violent
convictions so I mean what's important
what's the last violent um violent
conviction date right so is this
something that happened 20 years ago is
this something that happened two years
ago or one year ago because those are
the factors and judgment calls that
professionals can make when they see
that information
um again the pending cases you can see
things we have 100 counties in North
Carolina um people move people travel
across counties um people thinking about
like DWIs there was one instent where um
someone had when the system first went
live um they were treating DWI sometimes
like it was their first DWI in this
County but there was two other DWI in
two other counties across the state or
even next door where there are waiting
trial and those type of things so
understanding the totality of that
individual's or offender criminal
history and and what's pending and those
type of things you know allows them to
take take that action um the other thing
I should say is this is available 24 by7
um it's it's it's it's set up in a way
where you know active active where you
know you could have some when something
goes down you have another replicated
system come up so that there's very
little lag or downtime in this system
because of the criticality of what it
and who it serves and and what it
does um so if you go to the next page
this is a little uh a little different
uh uh spin on this system or a little
different highlight of this system so
you know I'm talking a lot about um
criminal justice and uh the the uh you
know having that information for those
professionals but there's other
important important information than it
surfaces and one thing that I think is
really important that came a little
later in this system was we work do a
lot of work with our Juvenile Justice um
department and we wanted to and and the
Juvenile Justice department in North
Carolina wanted this of course as well
and same with all the partners in this
um system they wanted to be able to
address opportunities to um Pro uh
identify programs across the state and
so you're seeing um a juvenile justice
service directory that's built into the
system and what I would say is um it
provides extensive search capability
again it's 100 counties um we have a lot
of services that we offer juveniles but
making sure that folks are aware of
where to go depending on the problem so
a law enforcement officer could use this
system and try and work with the family
and identify some services that may be
really important to them whether they're
um you know alcohol and drug mental
health aggression you know all these
different factors and they can search
regionally to provide that information
unlike the rest of the system where
you're very very um strict on what you
can print how you can print it who you
can provide it to if you do print it
this is one of those that you know print
print it will share it will um because
this is one of those just trying to
direct people to the right level of
services or or you know in their area
and where they live so this is a nice
add-on um to the system um um to provide
another different level of service that
you know wasn't what the original system
was designed to do over the course of
time there's additional features and
capabilities and there's also um
interactions with other systems such as
child welfare you know ensuring that you
know if something's happening in this
system that child welfare knows um for
there's another similar system that we
provided that looks like this that may
put again information a lot of this
information can't be shared with a child
welfare worker but what can be shared is
a child's at risk based on what we know
from this system you know something's
happening at a household or with an
individual um so some of that
information can flow into that system so
that you know it might be just call your
Police Department something happened at
this address call your you know re
directing to Services basically so again
um there's a lot of um what I call
extensibility to what we've done by
integrating this criminal justice data
and I'm going to talk a little bit more
about that on the next slide so you know
CJ leads what I'm showing to to you it's
amazing system 25,000 users and people
love it and I'm not trying to minimize
it but it's very operationally focused
right so when I say operationally
focused that's really what do I need to
do right now like in this situation what
do I need to do but as you integrate
this criminal justice data you start to
look at the research and the trend and
the forecasting to to really start to
answer different questions right and I'm
not showing you that side I'm showing
you the the kind of operational side and
those questions are what is happening
why is it happening um and what will
happen right what's the best predictor
on what may happen right so so you're
start to trying to answer different
questions but it's the same data that
you integrated it's just looking at it
differently and then you know taking
that third kind of lens on once you have
the integrated data is you know
obviously specifically in yall's
important roles with New Hampshire is
that policy development which is not
just what's happening how do we
intervene right um what's the impact on
our services and what's the impact our
investments you know what's the impact
on our with our investments on the
people of New
Hampshire
yep
yeah and you might want to include
there's so that's another one of those
complex um uh you know problems that
you'd probably need to look into Health
Data and other data so I would say it's
not just this system but your your your
um your use your use case is along those
um and so I'm actually done with the
formal presentation so I think I said
close you tell me can you tell me how
and if you link are you linked the
system linked to sieges so for example
um would a user be able to access a
triple I record through your user
interface interface so you're talking
about U more like the hot files yeah so
the federal level Federal level so if
you go back to that one chart the answer
is yes and sort of and I'll describe the
sort of okay it is linked from within
that system um we use in our state which
is what links it um our NC I through you
know so what we've done is uh for a
certain of users you can actually um
through CJ leads once you're in there be
able to authenticate through to receive
information on I believe it's the the I
think it's module one and two which are
the you know St stolen vehicles warrants
and those most important things are
what's included in the system and it's
identified on that table the details of
what's contained in that but the answer
is yes so would I be interested to with
an officer on the street say with a
mobile terminal when he runs an
individual be able to see if he has a
warrant from another state absolutely so
that's for so we have and this is where
the sort of comes in we have it for a
certain number of users because um
that's other that that functionality is
run through our state Bureau
Investigation and we've done an
integration and we've done an
integration for um Federal uh wanted and
missing persons um state vehicle um
excuse me I'm sorry stolen vehicles um
guns and other articles and then um out
ofate um driver's license in vehicle
registrations but it's been deployed to
a small subset of the system but it
could be deployed to the larger subset
in North Carolina you have a cost model
to be able to access that and so that's
kind of been the um the hurdle to be
able to deliver it to more folks so
that's where the sort of come in it's
done people are accessing it but it's
not uh for a a very large set of the
users yet I think the the federal um
through the FBI they're pretty limited
on who they will allow access to anyway
abely and the training as well that
comes with that Etc um and my and my
next question um related to that is that
I know by federal law the courts have to
have um protective orders entered within
minutes um uh is the court able to enter
protective orders through this system if
they were to have it um so
the answer to that's no and I should
have probably said this during the
presentation it's not that they couldn't
um but that's not the functionality
today so this system is really not
replicating any data I mean excuse me
it's only replicating data so it's not
um a system of record from like the
entry point of the data there's some
data that's created within it like audit
auditing you know logs and user you know
the user um interactions as well as
watch list and those type of things but
what's interesting about this system
which is probably no different than
other states is you have those Source
systems that state Silo this sits in the
middle of all of them and then it takes
in the information so like protective
orders soon as it's entered that's a
real-time service but it's not entered
in CJ
leads so in other words if you are a a
judge in a court and you issue a
protective order your clerk has to enter
it in CJ leads as well as into the
federal system so wherever they would
enter it into because they would enter
it at the state level as well and then
it would go to Federal it would then be
uh accessible through CJ leads so if
there's a a protective order that is in
the state so to speak we'll talk North
Carolina as soon as that is in the
system of record then that actually
would then be um come up on if if you're
searching a fender and there's a
protective order a real-time service
would go and check to see if there's
anything in that system and it would
surface that flag okay so they don't
have to make duplicate entries your
system captures what they enter into the
already existing system am I that is a
that is and I'm sorry to be informal I
should but um this is uh that's a really
good point across the whole system um
this is not a duplicate effort for
agencies the duplicate effort for
agencies is just from uh talk from
thinking about getting data into the
system is really participating and
understanding the data participating in
you know contributing their data through
some type of data file whatever you know
method we're going to use um and and
then potentially uh obviously receiver
be a receiver of access to that
information or access to the system for
looking a a more complete record not
just what they had in their own agency's
system but looking across all the
different um criminal histories and
interactions so your point um is
something I should have made which is
you don't enter data typically into the
system the systems
exist so we're already leveraging
Investments that have been made in those
systems as those systems change and
improve the data still continues to flow
into this
system okay so I'm I'm picturing your
system as kind of a spiderweb that
connects all these other different
things and it captures the information
so if I enter my information in my court
system your system's connected in the
background to capture that information
yes and that's how that gets in there
way absolutely and so um and you know
there's all sorts of business rules Etc
like expungements and those type of
things we account for that in the system
um but I would look at it more like a
kind of a hub and spoke yeah um this is
the one system you can go to that
captures cross Agency information I see
so the same agencies that are
contributing data are also the biggest
users of this data because they need to
see across the the actual now um
criminal justice data system again that
we have to be very plain and say it
really didn't exist before this okay um
next question I have is as far as
um data
analytics would someone be able to say I
would like to see um and I'm not sure
which agency would be the the place to
go to get data but if say for a
university wanted to do a study and say
we would like to see how many people of
um Lithuanian descent or or whatever um
have been arrested from this period to
this period on this charges and how many
went to jail how many didn't are you
able to capture that informator and
generate reports I'm going you know that
there's a the specifics of what you're
providing is is kind of like you know
probably depending on how it's asked is
the answer is no but in general research
researchers ability to to gain
information from the system what has
happened in the past is um agencies have
come to trust this Hub GAC and as
they're contributing their data for CJ
leads um you know there may be
additional uses for their data um that's
not for GAC to determine yeah that's for
really going back to the agency or or
going back to that researcher and saying
you're requesting information that's
involves these two agency or this one
agency here's who you need to talk to
yeah here's how you need Who who how you
need to approach them there may be forms
for that agency what the agency might do
just because we have experience with
that data they may say or have hey we
had this request come in for our data
you're already getting a feed is there
any way that you guys are maybe more
capable to get back this information to
this individual or you know or research
institution what we would then go back
to and speak this really speaks to the
data governance is go back and look at
our agreement and make sure that the
agreement accounts for that and if it
doesn't add it and sign that agreement
back between the agency um to ensure
responsibility with that data and then
yes we could potentially do that for
more specific let me let me drill it
down a little more um the counties in
Hampshire are siloed and um some of the
Court information you would literally
have to drive from court to court to
court if you wanted to get a a accurate
so if the court system wanted to query
its own
information to be able to generate some
type of report is that something they
could do um absolutely okay and so um
you know the difference and the nuances
between different states um North
Carolina has the um U the chief justice
that oversees the courts and then you
have local courts yeah um that that are
under that umbrella um for some things
um and technology is one of them so we
have one court system that spans all the
counties and all the courts even though
they may operate a little differently so
we're connecting into that one system
now if you had multiple systems across
um New Hampshire which I'm and I
apologize for being unaware then you
just have more Integrations okay okay um
now my last I think I have is regarding
um users so we have a bail commissioner
system and um we would like our bail
Commissioners to be able to have
realtime access and a lot of this
information was really good that showed
open cases um so because oftentimes they
may not be aware of uh a bail from
another County that was recently issued
that's so can we designate certain users
to have certain access to certain
systems only um
yes okay so so yeah the role base would
allow access to certain systems and
really drill down a little further into
certain data elements and those systems
and and that's where you know I'm
presenting North Carolina because it
seems like a really um interesting
business case to present you know to
inly
familiar yeah so I think that's a good
point but you know each state you know
has its own you know policies rules and
and positions on on what folks may be
able to or may not be able to access we
know a lot of that's Federal but again
it's how it's how it's done in um each
of the states and and part of it you
know really is you know there's a
training aspect um but part of it if
you're doing a new system you know you
don't want to throw everything at
everyone yeah so you may want to kind of
uh it's almost like building blocks you
want it to go quickly but you want it to
go right correct um so you want to make
sure the users understand everything
that's happening in the data in the
release and you also don't want to go
too fast and assign wrong Privileges and
you want to make sure that everyone
understands what they can have access to
and so that's diving into also the
business cases right to document that
you know um yeah this data might be nice
to have but it's not for you right now
yeah okay type deal and and it's
bidirectional so that the bail
commissioner would be able to not only
see but enter the bail and the
conditions of bail they set and so that
the judge would see that in other police
departments and bail so that's how it
could work okay again that might be more
specific to your bail system but the
idea of that I guess my questions are is
it capable of oh absolutely right it's
just another source system um so it's
just another source of data okay so um
again you know thinking about North
Carolina North Carolina didn't start
with these I don't know 25 different you
know large data sets you know it started
with what was the most important in the
pilot right those things that we want to
integrate as quickly as possible um
don't boil the ocean and then start
layering in additional data yeah um
twofold one is as North Carolina this
this group becomes more capable with it
and then the other is you know you don't
want to try and do too much and and
create the spider whip um you want to do
do you want to be effective be targeted
do it the right way and be successful
and show value and then grow from there
okay thank you um questions from the
committee members um representative rhs
thank you Mr chairman and I apologize if
you answered this but I was taking care
of getting the heat turned off in here
so you're all welcome
um the the information
that I know that the committee I speak
to everybody is very interested in is
already out there floating in somewhere
land how does that information get put
in here in the first place yeah so so I
think there's oh permission to answer
questions sorry okay I've been out of
government a little while so I'm I'm you
know my testimony skills are a little
lower than they have been some
committees are a little stricter I
prefer our back and forth conversational
we get more information that way so feel
free to thank you Mr chair um so that's
twofold one is um you know uh the the
the data governance piece is huge and
can't be ignored and so data governance
is is really important and what I would
say is data governance is getting all
the right people around the table
laying out shared and clear
objectives um and and being able to have
those hard conversations to get to yes
we're going to share our data then
there's the technical side of it right
and that's that data integration piece
and you know um that that technology
deployment and those type of things both
of those go hand inand um but there has
to be you know there has to be people
that want to make that happen um and you
know again I think you know the
legislature is probably in in a great
position to to help um kind of spur that
along um but I a lot of this is really
soft when it's about just people and
organizations working together there's
privacy concerns there's a whole slew of
things that need to be addressed and and
folks need to address those but again it
really comes down to working together
objectives represent brh I I think the
answer to your question was probably
answer to my question is the information
gets in the
system when the agency enters it in
their system their system captures it so
is that answer
so if I may once upon a time before I
decided to be a state legislator I sold
real estate and one of the things that
drove me crazy is that I had to pay and
pay and pay and then I had to belong to
the multi list system system and then
Along Came
realtor.com and Zillow and you they all
came along and they took the information
that I paid to put into one system and
then they took it and then wanted me to
pay for that other system that they
already took my information from so I
understand the the whole spider weip
thing but
I'm so how so but it has to somehow get
in there in the first place so does it
just say hey we're going to take it now
that we were told or does somebody have
to actually yeah so working with the
agencies from a technical perspective
depending on there's many methods to
bring that data into the system I think
what you're describing screen scrapes
and other types of things that's not
what we would do um we would actually
work with the agency that's contributing
data to put into the system to have a
formalized process of them pushing the
data to a certain place um very secure
uh with the right encryption and those
type of thing so um no one else can
access it unless you're on the other
side have the keys and those type of
things so it might be pushed or you know
you may go in and grab that data um but
again on the real time it's a real-time
connection into that database to pull
things like warrants and protective
orders and maybe DMV pictures and those
type of things because you don't you
want to get that real time you may not
want to wait till you know once or twice
or three times a day so it is a formal
movement of data for most of it and then
there's um there's actually then some
real-time data connections that happen
question yep and there has to be
agreements in place and those type of
things to ensure that it's secure Etc so
you could have scheduled nightly uploads
Y and also at the same time throughout
the day realtime access from the same
user yep yep and and and sometimes uh
you
know this is an interesting space right
so I mentioned expungements that's
that's complicated right cuz because
it's expunged you shouldn't see it so so
there's some data that comes in for
North Carolina at least that's a full
file reload every single night because
some data may disappear and it's it's
gone for good right so there's things
like that you have to account for which
are the business processes and the
policies Etc and and they may be unique
to each state that you just need to
address um I I have another one case um
so we talked about criminal justice and
the aspect of that is is um the
DMV so on a timeline how long would it
take to implement a system like this
that tied in the the court the law
enforcement and the DMB yeah so that's a
a great question that assuming everybody
agreed everybody
participated so you know that's a great
question that I would love to answer in
more detail but I would need to
understand more about the
systems um and the architectures and
those typee of things um but I think
what to me a logical approach would be
is to take kind of a step forward and a
step back at the same time which might
be to actually document all that over
maybe a period of three months um and go
hard at that to understand exactly what
you're going to do and then figure out
the timeline from there is it six months
is a year um some of that depends on the
resources being ready to be able to get
the files ready and those type of things
at the agencies and so there's factors
in there and again I apologize for not
answering your question directly but you
know I think that um you know obviously
I think it's probably within a year
that's for sure could you based on your
historical with North Carolina how long
did it take them to to get at least that
aspect I I understand that there
potential for different modules to be
added but I think what would be um if if
allowed what I'd like to do is go back
and present some of that information
after this this that's okay um because I
can look back and see what where do we
start first again where we started in
North Carolina this is New Hampshire
it's not North Carolina I want to
recognize that um and uh you know so
where they started may be a different
starting place for you what would be
nice to understand is to understand what
are those um where do where would you
start what scope what agencies first
yeah so identify prioritize which what
data is most important but we can
generalize you know based on what we
know in our our past history of
delivering um this for North Carolina
and happy to get back to you on that
thank you um representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman can you tell us a
little bit about the Contracting process
that you had to go through in North
Carolina and other states and what you
think that would look like here in New
Hampshire if we were to contract with
you yeah so um
that's a very good question so from a
Contracting process uh you know in North
Carolina uh again North Carolina
contracted with SAS we had other
engagements with SAS to do this work um
and it was you know annual agreements
that continue to get renewed with
additional Scopes and um uh scope of
works and Etc to continue to enhance um
maintain and and build out the system
some more um so we'd have to talk about
the you know that's North Carolina but
as far as the Contracting procedures in
New Hampshire I'm not as familiar with
um all of the different methods yeah we
have different statutes that would have
to and and also we'd have to discuss I
don't even know um you know we have
different branches of government
involved that would have to also agree
it would be complex yeah it's complex I
mean and and again I mean you know where
it resides and who signs the contract is
probably the you know know those first
questions again those are details that I
I'm sorry I can't address at a detailed
level but that's a great question that's
fine this all just things bouncing in
our heads uh representative wheeler
thank you again Mr chairman um aside
from that uh and when the system is
implemented uh SAS is the one who runs
the servers and have you guys had any
problems with glitches while implemented
or anything else which has uh made
implementation a rocky process so not
the implementation so you know can I
answer that two ways okay so one way is
um that you know some of the some of the
glitches are at the start getting those
folks around the table formulating a
committee and getting people to make
sure that we all agree on what we're
trying to do and accomplish um that's
probably I'm not going to say that's a
glitch but that's your first Challenge
and that's the most important challenge
right across the agencies um from
glitches in the system absolutely um I
don't know if there's 's a system I've
ever gone to that is runs perfectly all
the time um I'm happy to provide the
uptime and the stats this system when I
was I'm going to put my state of North
Carol Carolina hat on if the system was
going to be down and it rarely went down
very rarely went down but if it was
going to go down for more than an hour I
was going to be in contact with the
governor's office I never contacted the
governor's office so that's probably a
better way to answer that but but I
don't want to I I I know I've been
mentioning this many times around data
governance and and getting the folks
headed in the right direction but that
is you know super critical even to make
sure the system accomplishes what it's
setting out to do and and a system when
I say the system setting out what it's
accomplishing to do documenting what all
the expectations are to make sure the
system meets those expectations and and
so you know I would say that you know
and this isn't speaking for CJ Le this
is speaking across all the different
systems I've been involved in um you
know when a system comes up of seeing
where people that's not what I wanted
and what has happened often times is
that those that contribute and
participate maybe don't participate
enough right here's my data we'll see
you later um and we're going to use the
system when it's up it's no here's my
data let's talk through the data let's
talk about the quirks on the data let's
walk through some of the data quality
issues we know exist let's document
those let's document why you don't want
to use this field and those type of
things um so it's imparting knowledge
and it's imparting kind of that shared
responsibility on making sure the system
is going to do what it's going to do and
and I just want to again I don't mean to
be continuing to harp on it but it's not
just throwing the data over the wall
it's providing the data with
participation so basically you get into
the system what you what you you get out
of it what you put absolutely yes sir as
far as not just information but time
effort and yes what you want y thank you
representative
Newman thank you Mr chair um my question
has to do with what this committee might
want out of some of this data and so one
of the things that I recall as an
example would be we have discussions
about ethnicity and it's for the
purposes of understanding whatever
ethnicity is out there and how it's
gathered by the police in the various
places it ends up in
databases um and there are problems with
that like the drop- down menu with it
the way that an officer on on at at a
stop has to report data is by a drop-
down menu and they select a limited
number of things based upon whether or
not they get data from the individual or
not so how so your system if it were
implemented would only be able to gather
up all the various databases across the
state and the the counties and stuff
like that and pull it into one place and
then do your magic on it and we might be
able to get better data but it would be
reliant on how good the systems are for
collecting that data and keeping in a
database is that correct it it is
absolutely correct yes so it's not the
source system of Entry it's it's the
aggregator of all these various systems
to bring that in um so yeah absolutely
thank you represent numo help because I
I think I was trying to ask the same
question before with my Lithuanian
example um I believe that the problem we
have now is the courts capture that
information better than the police do
but the court being able to access it
because it's spread out at different
courts everywhere you can't pull a
report so I feel like we would if we had
a system like that you would be able to
go to the court and they would be able
to pull their information that's stored
there and get what they needed to give
to us um versus the police well wherever
the database is it's whatever however
good the way you can enter the data then
the data is stored somewhere correct
once it's just stored in the data system
you can though go to the various Data
Systems and get it out Bring it together
and then maybe this committee would
perhaps get a report on on what had
happened for all of the arrests in the
in the state of New Hampshire
potentially can I respond to that a
little bit more you would but I I just I
my understanding and you correct me in
your response we wouldn't go to you we
would go to the court and say get the
data that's stored on their system y to
give us they they're a repository they
don't give out data the outside sources
they give it to the people who put it in
so we would have to ask them for a
specific report but right now the court
has no such ability because of their
various silos with a system like this
the court would have it all in one place
I think but please no that's that's
exactly right and but I do definitely
want to respond once we you know started
Living with this system in the state of
North Carolina you started to see data
quality issues and so the users started
to see some of those data quality issues
as well because they're seeing it all
put together so I will say that the data
quality improved after the system was
released because you could see some
inconsistencies and so the source
systems May again some data can never be
updated just by Statute in North
Carolina I'm sure in all states but some
data can be and so there was Data
corrections made on many different
things to improve the data collection
process um so it's a it's a great point
but again CJ leads is kind of that Hub
and the source systems are around that
Hub and the data flows into the CJ leads
uh uh repository for lack of a better
work
in North Carolina is Corrections also in
in your using that system yes so they
track everything from who's there how
long they're there what the charges are
for yes everything okay everything yep
that would be I I shouldn't say
everything but I'm not sure if it's
everything but yeah want to put in there
all the critical uh probation parole all
that yes so okay so if as a legislator
we man legislature we mandated uh
corrections to capture certain data and
report to us on a yearly basis they
would be easily as long as they put it
in as we told them to be able to pull it
right back up y it's another source and
the detail within that Source could be
brought in yes sir thank you very much
uh represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman quick followup for my research
purposes just to make sure that I got
these numbers right um SAS is in 134
countries servicing 25,000 users in 700
counties is that
correct there 700 agencies oh so so um
I'll let you speak to the the corporate
but go ahead and I'll speak to C and
then the one follow-up question I had
for that was also what other states um
and if it's a comprehensive list feel
free to just send it afterwards but um
yeah I'd like to know what other the
states sis is service great question
representative wheeler um so just to
clarify so we are actually we are in
1600 there are 1600 departments and
bureaus and commissions where we serve
for as sasas so um as an example I right
now uh I so I live in Massachusetts the
state of Massachusetts and we do work
with certain agencies there um one of
the and I will I will add that there is
some critical work that we've done in
relation to the opiate crisis and so a
lot of what you're talking about with
the data very sensitive data that
they're dealing with at the moment so um
but we the the backbone of the an
analysis that's being done is used by S
is is done through SAS so um as far as
numbers are concerned I mean those
numbers are growing in terms of where we
are um but for the most part 134 uh uh
different agencies across the
world and so and then 1600 and plus or
more give or take across the the
different states can I just can I just
add to that so sorry it's 134 different
countries and then government entities
within that um and for CJ leads so I
think some of it was mixed up with the
CJ leads metric
so I'll I'll say the CJ leads metrics we
say over 25,000 I think it's 26,000 to
27,000 users
um officers courts
prosecutors um there's a whole list of I
don't know if it's about 13 different
roles um there's 100 counties that in
North Carolina that have access to this
um you know there are um some federal
agencies supporting North Carolina that
have access to this um and so
it's it's pretty broad user group from
the criminal justice Community it's not
just for law enforcement it is for you
know a broader view of Criminal Justice
um and then I'm trying to think if there
was other metrics that you were looking
for oh we're basically in all the states
and it's just different domain areas so
there's a lot of um a lot of Health
agencies use SAS
epidemiologist CJ not specifically CJ
leads is not in another state
um but you know we have a lot of
investigative case management and other
type of and Jake had mentioned fusion
centers um and other type of criminal
justice state integration activities um
but it's not here here's CJ Leeds it's
built on the same technology um CJ Leeds
is one of those branded um it's really
branded for North Carolina but if you
look at what's behind CJ leads it's our
primary SAS tools that are deployed
across um a variety of Industries and
and specifically government so if we
were to um engage with your company we
could call it whatever we wanted it
didn't have to be CJ leads I would hope
you would and and so you know um when I
was G the the deputy State CIO I
encouraged agencies to Brand Solutions
or Enterprise solutions that cut across
agencies it helps gain Buy in it it
becomes you know it's it's becomes your
baby um you know we're we're happy and I
think a lot of technology companies are
happy to do this that you know almost be
behind the scenes be the intelligence
behind the scenes that's delivering
information um but really we encourage
you to call things what you want that
gets Buy in in commitment from your
state did you talk about the fusion I
know I I understand fusion centers but
could you explain it to the members
please about the different agencies that
involved in a fusion Center
yeah so um we we are in I believe about
16 different fusion centers across the
United States right now um and so fusion
centers the primary goal of the fusion
centers is to share data between
different agencies at a local level at a
state level with the federal government
um our software the same foundational
software right that CJ leads is running
on the backbone that you know the Hub
and spoke model pulling together
different systems of of record right
your CAD your M data your SAR data all
that data is being aggregated together
into a single system and then provided
to the different users of that Fusion
Center um for the different
investigative or intelligence needs that
they may have um in their given um
jurisdiction and just for clarification
that's usually um anti-terrorism type
operations um um Tri child trafficking
high level
stuff any further questions from the
Comm uh representative Pratt
I see North Carolina has um oh I have a
question for you North Carolina has a uh
gun registry and you mentioned the
federal government has access to
that I'm sorry I couldn't hear the
question uh North Carolina seems to have
a gun registry yes uh we had a pistol
per purchase permit program that was run
by the sheriffs that is set to Sunset
there's not going to be that program
anymore it may have Sunset it or it's
sunsetting in Jan January so there's no
um that was a program that basically um
the sheriff's had um issued permits and
those type of things and that's that's
done away with completely so the federal
government will still have access to the
old records or the old record so you're
talking about Nicks the what we just
what we send up to Nicks from concealed
handguns yes um well that's not
concealed handguns this is purchasing
guns I think what the representative is
concerned about is we don't want a
record of our guns purchased in the
Hampshire accessible to the federal
government I and I don't think that
would be the case at all other than they
what they already get from what they
already get which would be from the um
TR from the um FFL which would be the
disqual offenses that disqualify you
from having a gun yeah absolutely so so
just a follow-up question so a follow-up
question is slightly different uh so
you're you're collecting well you're
accessing massive amount of data and so
who has access to that outside of the
justice system outside of and I'm
thinking basically uh like a breakdown
of if you want to break down the silos
you going to have to assure that
insurance companies real estate
companies corporations banks credit card
companies wouldn't have any access to
any of ab not one piece of it AB no not
one piece and this needs to be
transparent so all of our Agreements are
very transparent and are also updated
frequently or Revisited to make sure
that everyone's abiding by them Etc but
no this is this is uh you know
everything should be transparent and
should be understanding what's going on
even our privacy our our policies excuse
me I'm going I'm with sass I keep
getting confused where where I work so
apologize but even if you go to CJ Le's
website you'll see all the information
you'll even see the um the policies and
and and access agreements that are out
there that everyone has to sign so it's
right there and says what you can do and
what you can't do with that data um
thank you yep yes
sir have you ever been
no representative Stone thank you uh
just to clarify obviously as a vendor
you'd be able to uh give us a catered
version of what we would want that would
not conflict with obviously information
or rsas or state laws that would
prohibit certain information levels so
that when you would get the uh contract
as a vendor you would basically
categorize everything in compliance to
what we would request as a state correct
absolutely your terms and conditions and
your laws um you know I'm presenting
North Carolina as a use case I'm not
here to sell this tool for you um this
is a good use case that I think
represents some of the challenges I've
heard with New Hampshire um but whatever
we would do for any State uh not just
New Hampshire I just want to speak
vanilla um which would we would abide by
um the the laws and statutes of that
state and the contracts would reflect
and respect um the laws and statutes of
that state and it's not even just that
it might even be just the business
processes that you know maybe it's the
it processes it's it architectures and
those type of things those things would
need to be addressed by in collaboration
between um you really like working with
any vendor um that you would expect from
to do business with New Hampshire we
would honor those same type of uh uh uh
respect and and and discussion questions
thank you yes sir and just for the one
more time I'll reiterate it for the
committee they are using North Carolina
because first of all that's the only
state that I'm aware of that they're
they do this but also they have the
exact same during the opening their
opening of the presentation it they
could have easily been describing to
Hampshire with regard to silad
information that's not connected and our
bail commissioner is not able to access
information real time and so it as I
said hauntingly familiar but anything
any company we entered into an agreement
with or explored this with would tailor
it specifically to our statutes our
regulations and what we ask them to
do any further
questions seeing none um we really
appreciate you coming here today to
share this with us and I hope to stay in
touch and um uh I'm going to speak to
the different agency heads and and see
where that leads us we appreciate your
time time thank you very much thank you
and I and I'll stay in contact UM for
any further information and if you want
to share further information based on
the questions you heard today we can um
please send it and I'll make sure the
committee gets it sounds great thank
thank you very much appreciate you um
with that we are going to take a break
back
um at this time we're going to begin
again and we have several um people to
speak to us from the counties I would
invite them to come forward um whichever
one has to leave
sist and I do apologize if I had
understood the time crunch I would have
didn't Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is George mcis I'm
chairman of the board of County
Commissioners in straford County I'm
also president of all the County
Commissioners uh in New Hampshire I have
served in that capacity as president of
all the County Commissioners for over 25
years I'm serving my 19th term on the
board of County Commissioners in
straford we've been doing pre-trial
programming I'm sorry this is Carrie
Conway joined with me she's our director
of our alternative sensing programs in
straford we started about 25 years ago
uh doing pre-trial diversion uh as a
result of the fact that since I've been
County Commissioner I've built three
County
jails so the programs we put in place
were uh
designed uh to to uh level the playing
field for lack of a better term we had
people sitting in jail on $200 and $300
cash bail uh that they couldn't pay yet
had spent uh back then sometimes uh two
to three months uh by the time they got
before a judge a judge would just
release them based on time served uh and
uh that's how the system used to be uh
since that time uh and we had all kinds
of other uh different types of
characteristics that don't exist today
uh but with the programs we put in place
uh we're doing pre-trial uh assessment
on uh individuals that are are going to
be at some point incarcerated or not
incarcerated uh as just I just want to
issue any one of the programs that
straford county has started and we've we
call it our same Justice sooner model
that's what we call it the same Justice
sooner model uh has anywhere from a 4:1
to a 10:1 savings N9 to1 savings uh for
the property taxpayer as you know all
County jails are supported by the
property tax uh every one of these
programs we put in place have that type
of cost
savings so I'm going to have Carrie
Conway talk a little bit about pre-trial
assessment how we do it uh how the
system works
uh so that when you're working through
all these bills that you folks have Mr
chairman uh you might want to consider
uh doing this in All Counties not all
counties do this uh simply because they
don't uh there has different
philosophies on on uh whether they
should be doing it uh some people think
that we should just raise the bail and
keep them in jail we have that theory
out there we have some people that say
the people shouldn't pay any bail at all
uh there's a lot of PR going on uh
people forget the reasons why we have
bail we have bail for specific reasons
the main one is to make sure you show up
for court now I can tell you that
nationally uh there's about a 60%
escorpion rate that people don't show to
court when they're supposed to in
straford County we have a 9% rate with
one of the leaders in the country when
it comes to not making sure people show
up for court and the reason for that is
is because of the work that we do that
Carrie does with her staff uh and doing
pre-trial assessments so I'm going to
have her talk a little bit about that
and then answer any questions you might
have good
morning thank you for having us today um
so the something I really want to focus
on is the risk assessment tool that we
use in straford County um every day
Monday through Friday our pre-trial
officers enter the Department of
Corrections and conduct a public safety
assessment on people that have been
booked into the to Jail the night prior
um we asked them a list of questions and
I brought I brought copies of our um
assessment that we use I could pass out
after or
now thanks
yeah I'm sorry that's every Monday that
that's done um we do it Monday through
Friday okay every
day and so the public safety assessment
it's important to use a scientifically
studied tool when you're asking
questions the the tool um relies heavily
on criminal histories but also gives us
room um to add in collateral information
so we focus heavily on people's ties to
the community are they
employed um their past criminal offenses
have we had them on supervision prior we
make assessments on bail we send reports
to the judges before the defendant
appears in court we send the the
assessments out to the public defenders
and also to the prosecutors so everyone
goes to court prepared with an
assessment in front of them
we currently have
375 people out on pre-trial Supervision
in straford County um as commissioner
mallis mentioned we have about a 9.2
failure to appear rate one thing to take
into consideration when you're thinking
about pre-trial programs is there's no
one siiz fits-all to monitor someone in
the community we monitor people from
second deegree assaults to domestic
violence to possession charges to DWIs
you name it um
we spend the time interviewing each
person and we come up with a case
management plan with them so if we think
about pre-trial we're supposed to think
the least amount of restrictions you not
you know people haven't been found
guilty yet so we have at our at our in
our toolkit we have um electronic
monitoring devices that we can use for
GPS for um we we get that ordered a lot
on domestic violence Vic for domestic
violence survivors and victims um we
have a Bart which is a device that
people blow into to test if they're
drinking alcohol we do drug testing we
have curfews we have telephonic
supervision where people that we
identify as more low risk on our case
loads call in every night to check in at
a curfew time so we really tailor our
assessment uh these this tool is
evidence-based we we um attend a
conference every year a National
Conference where we talk about the
newest things in pre-trial supervision
and we try to adapt to that
um I didn't know if you had any specific
questions for us as to what we do in
straford I'm happy to answer I could
give you a lot of information about what
we do dayto
day if if this is something it's my
understanding um it's regarded highly in
the community uh Statewide um that we
would contemplate um dealing with on a
on implementing on a Statewide level I'd
like to hear whatever you want to share
about um uh implementation of the system
cost of the system
um uh necessary employees to manage it
um everything everything you want to
share yeah all great questions so the
the cost of our programs it's about an 8
to1 cost
savings incarceration per day correct
yeah and and on I do actually have some
other charts to show you that show um
our costs of programs and incarcerations
for the last um since 2010 so I'm happy
to share that with the committee as well
if I if I could Mr
chairman one of the things that you want
to do when you talk about a pre-trial
assessment uh is that you have to have
the other side of the stool here which
which is the active use of drug court
mental health court uh we have a for
lack of a better term a dead beat dad
program we have we we used to have
people that would spend time in jail
because they wouldn't pay their child
support as an example well that doesn't
make a lot of sense because while
they're in jail they lose their job uh
so we have a program that does that so
we have a number of different programs
that were all designed to provide
alternative s sentencing but also arrive
at the same
result the same Justice Just
sooner so with that in mind what would
happen
is
uh in order for the count all counties
to do this like for instance it doesn't
make a lot of sense for Coos they
probably got nine prisoners in jail the
last time I worked with the Coos County
Commissioners uh several years ago
probably seven or eight years ago I
don't I really didn't understand why
they were running a jail uh I thought
they ought to contract with with the
state and use the state prison in Berlin
um but with that said not all counties
are the same not All Counties have
services available to them uh to be able
to do some of the things that straford
does the biggest the certainly the
larger counties could do it the smaller
counties might have to we might have to
be a little flexible as to how they
would they would go about doing uh
alternative sentencing uh when you
really get right down to it that's what
with the bail system the the
incarceration system the two two-tiered
system of Corrections we have in New
Hampshire
uh uh it's an it's an old system no
question about it okay there's an old
it's an old
system
but we're watching right now over 500
people in the community we have 80
sentenced prisoners in our jail this
morning 80 sentenced with over
500 uh uh that were watching in the
community if we didn't have the alter
alternative sentencing program at
least 40 45 maybe up to 50% of those
people would be in the county jail now
when that occurs you take on the
responsibility for a lot of costs Health
Care specifically okay their health care
costs and I don't have to tell you the
cost of health care it's dramatic and
it's gone up hundredfold in 25
years so there are other things that go
on in people people's lives when we do
this assessment tool we talk about
whether they're employed what they have
going on in their lives what's going on
specifically with them uh and that's a
model that's been Su we've actually been
recognized nationally as a leader uh in
the area of alternative sentencing uh
we've had a a tremendous track record
knock on wood uh so far uh and we've
been doing it for many many years now so
a lot of the counties in the beginning
will have to crawl before they could run
uh and there's an expense involved in
that and a lot of places a lot of places
don't particularly believe in
alternative sentencing program a lot of
people think you should just lock them
up and throw away the key well we locked
them up and throw away the key in
straford county for many many years
that's what I told you earlier I built I
built three County jails and I had
National Consultants come in and tell me
what size jail we should build and we
would build it and three years later it
would be overcrowded
the third time around we decided to try
to do business a little differently and
look at the actual demographics of who
we had in jail and the reasons why they
were
there and when you look at that and you
assess that okay it changes your
attitude about why we incarcerate people
and the reasons for it we like to
incarcerate people because we're mad at
them we're mad at at the at the things
that they've done in the community
well when I first went around and talked
to Rotary clubs and Chambers of Commerce
in my County we have three cities in
straford County when I first talked
about trying to change the criminal
justice system way we did business I
used to tell them what would you rather
do would you rather have would you
rather have us watching somebody having
them keep their
job okay and pay you
restitution or would you rather me put
them in jail for 60 days which would you
prefer because when people commit most
of these these crimes are being
committed those folks with drug
addiction or
alcoholism 70% of the of the crimes that
they commit are property crimes so when
they break in your house and they steal
your TV or they steal your computer or
whatever they're going to take your
jewelry not only is that person uh they
contact their insurance company they
have a $500 or ,000 deductible that
they're going to have to pay okay they
want some form of restitution well the
person can't pay a restitution if
they're sitting in jail
so there are instances where it makes
sense to use them monitor them monitor
them in the community in some instance
now we have jails for reasons some
people belong in jail okay we have them
for reasons but I the history that we've
been able to develop in straford County
over the period of time have have taught
us a few lessons number one that people
when I talked to those people at Rotary
and Chamber of Commerce they said give
me my
restitution I don't I don't care about
the 60 days I want my restitution so
we're able to do those types of things
over time uh that affect society greatly
now straford County only has 130,000
people in it about 132,000 people half
of them are children so let's just take
the adult population we're talking about
70 to 74,000 people we have 500 people
were watching right now when I was first
elect the county commissioner 40 years
ago we had 16
prisoners we had a part-time County
attorney it was Prosecuting crime we the
grand jury met once a year we've had a
lot of changes in society since then but
we've also learned a lot of lessons from
that and one of them is to do pre-trial
assessments and do alternative
sentencing it works it doesn't only work
in our County but it works across the
country those those c those areas of the
country that that have embraced that
type of
sentencing uh and it works but you have
to do the assessments and you have to do
best
practices so my suggestion to the
committee was if you really want to look
at this is have the count is to pay the
counties because most counties don't
want to raise property
taxes historically they have not wanted
to raise property taxes to help the
folks who commit
crime however if they do it the right
way we've demonstrated that it saves
money it saves a lot of money but you
have to do it a certain way and it would
be in the counties it would be in the
state's interest to have the counties do
this and the reason why let me tell you
why is that you want an independent
opinion when you do these assessments
you don't want the judicial branch to
run it you don't want prosecutors
running it you don't want public
defendant program want running it you
want an independent an an independent
assessment done on folks so when that
assessment goes before a judge it's
another tool that the judge can use uh
to determine how they want to handle
that individual case that's what it
really boils down to is giving judges
Alternatives years ago judges didn't
have Alternatives they either let you go
or they raised your bail and as a result
of that a lot of people who couldn't
afford to pay actually their bail
sometimes was more more than their
actual sentenced
fine in many instances because they had
to go through a
trial so those are just some of the
things that I would suggest that if you
want to look at it and we can spend some
more time it with you Mr chairman I
don't want to take any more time with
the committee but we would certainly
like to answer any questions you may
have but it seems to me that if we made
money some form of cash available to the
counties and have them emble have them
work with the National Association of
counties and those counties across the
country that have been successful at
doing this uh you'd have a different
result for New Hampshire
so with that will answer any questions
you may
have when you envision um giving money
to the counties
um since this program if uh implemented
properly would result in cost savings I
I I think of perhaps seed money to to
start their programs and then the
program should be almost
self-funding versus the cost is Right
saving depending on the nature of the
size of the
like for instance Coos would have
difficulty doing because they have
Rockingham yeah well Rockingham
certainly could Rockingham certainly
could do it uh you know expand they have
a great mat program in Rockingham
um the larger counties if they had the
seed money and there was a
philosophical change and how we approach
the
incarcerated um yes you're right that
they would they would eventually they
would eventually start to save money a
lot of these facilities though were
built a lot of Old County jails were
built um you have a stand you have you
have overhead you have Staffing um a lot
of them were built under the old way of
doing business for lack of a better term
uh we've been fortunate in straford
County when we built our new jail the
latest jail we built it with a maximum
flexibility so we can we're able to shut
down certain sections of it uh if we
don't need it uh we we were successfully
in uh getting negotiating Federal
contracts with with the federal
government with the uh with the ice with
the US Customs and enforcement and with
the uh US Federal Marshall service so we
uh rent out our jail space uh to the
feds which gives us Revenue which also
helps to offset the cost of some of
these things a lot of those counties
aren't going to be able to do that
because they the physical plant's not
capable of doing it so they would need
that they would need that money that
seed money uh and you'd have to look at
it again over a course of time to see
how successful they were being
on and I know this is probably an
impossible question to ask but you know
what kind of money are we talking about
to to implement or start a program a
pilot if you will for a lack of a better
term what I'll do is I'll look at that
and and ship you those kind of cost
estimates to you in the committee and
the you know at some point it would be
different in every County again
depending on the nature of of how broad
their alternative sentencing programs
would be uh and whether it makes sense
in some instances like for instance in
Coos I probably would make little and no
sense for many of those
things if last time I looked at Coos I'm
not trying to pick on Coos but it's the
smallest county we have and they've only
got probably somewhere between 9 and 16
prisoners at any one time in their in
their County jail and I think you would
find that most of them are there for
drug rated
offenses if they're there for recreation
use that's
one that would be one set of
circumstances if they're there for
dealing that's another so if you had a
robust small part-time drug court in in
Coos that was up and running you may not
need the jail at
all however one of the things that's
interesting about Coos and you'll find
this in the smaller counties as well is
that the county is an employment base
for their people
if they were to shut the jail down they
would lay off you know 30 40 50 people
and that's a huge employment base uh for
that region so they don't they don't
want it they don't want the reform so
those are the kinds of questions you're
going to run into in the smaller
counties but there's no question in the
larger counties there would be a
long-term cost savings smaller counties
we'd have to work on it a little bit
well I would I would Envision um a piece
at a time for example I I like the con
ccept and I think the committee shares
this of electronic monitoring versus
incarceration where someone could still
go to work but you know what they're
doing at all times of the day where they
are
um the cost associated with that we've
heard depends on who's want if you're
running it yourselves it cost less than
if you contract with the company um are
you able to recoup any of the money from
the defendant since they are working
those type of things so I I would be
interested to see what components make
up your pre-trial system that could be
used even in a small County like Coos
they may may be able to empty half the
jail if they could put them on an ankle
monitor absolutely and a program of
monitoring no no question about that and
I'll get that we'll make sure we'll
forward that to you okay also um what is
your interaction with probation and
parole do how do you um interact with
them well we got car you can ask that I
mean probation and parole in straford
county is in our building oh so which is
nice yeah it's across the hall across
the hall yeah so um fortunately and UNT
fortunately we we do get a lot of the
people that we set up on pre-trial we
have them for x amount of days we get
them sober they have a job they're doing
what they're supposed to do they get
sentenced and then they get sentenced to
state probation parole and for us one of
the success and functions of pre-trial
is we keep our case load small for a
reason because studies will show you
that you're supposed to do that that's
how you work more effectively with
people so we have case loads of about 50
people per staff probation parole their
numbers up around 150 200
250 so we often will see that we get
someone set up on pre-trial and they're
abiding members of the society again and
then they unfortunately fall apart
pretty quickly when they're getting
minimal supervision and minimal
interactions um due to staffing issues
at probation parle through the state but
we do get co- um supervised people
there's people that we get on new
charges that are already on probation
and parole and we have a great working
it would be helpful to the committee if
you could explain um because New
Hampshire is is cble together um with
old laws and new laws and systems how
how someone um ends up under the
jurisdiction of your pre-trial system
could they be ordered there from a state
judge based on a state charge and um you
know the county versus State and the
state orders you to do something with
somebody incarcerate them do they give
you money to pay for that how how does
works so someone's arrested brought to
our our jail um in our County the bail
Commissioners will often recommend
Community someone PR bail with Community
Corrections so if they're arrested on a
Sunday they'll say PR bail show up
Community Corrections tomorrow morning
at 10: a.m. um we also get people
ordered straight from Court um we have
people come down that the judge say said
I'm on supervision with you now I'm here
we get people who were out on uh
probation parole violations that we were
monitoring on new charges so we see all
life and what if any reimbursement from
the state does the county get for any of
that service that is ordered by the
reimbursement
um any other questions from the
representative Newman hold on thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I think what I just want to
make sure I understood what you just
said for people that are on Personal
recognizance bail you get to see them
sometimes all the time not or how does
it or is it just incarcerated people so
people that are so some people will get
PR bail and some people will get PR bail
with posted with us with Community
Corrections the the people that are
straight PR we don't we don't
see thank
you representative Stone thank you thank
you for taking my question you sparked
us something that I thought about if you
have somebody that's on probation or
parole and they're charged with a
subsequent offense which is a new charge
why would you want to absorb the cost of
monitoring them on a pre-trial when the
probation department has much more
Authority and a mechanism to deal with
them and basically they have the
resources as well why would you want to
basically double dip well the judge
orders them to us so if it's a new
charge they're not they're they're not
being if they're on probation that
they're not being sent back to jail or
prison on a new charge it's a new charge
so they have to you know it's either
they sit in jail or they come out into
the community and we monitor them just
follow up on that typically with
probation violations and uh parole
violations it's triggering mechanism for
a type of hearing to go forward if they
are charged with that again I just don't
understand why you'd want to absor the
costs if it's the same type of
supervision that would be handled by the
state yeah we don't we don't like to
absorb the
cost until we had a new statute the
counties push for a new statute what
would happen if somebody for instance
violated a state parole let me give you
a quick example this one I always talk
about because it was it's the truth and
it
happened we had somebody out on on state
parole who uh was not require was
required not to do any drugs or alcohol
went to their brother's birthday party
and had a
beer probation officer found he had a
beer had him arrested and they put him
in the county jail he sat in the county
jail for 60 days because he had a beer
at his
party now we changed we got the laws
changed since then now you have to have
a hearing within 72 hours uh so they
wouldn't sit in county jail for a very
long period of time but depending on the
nature of what what the violation is
like for instance the beer at the
brother's birthday party uh a judge in
that case would just turn around and say
okay well we'll put them on Community
Corrections uh you know because you
shouldn't have had the beer instead of
putting them back in state prison as as
as a quick example now should the county
absorb that
cost probably not however that's our
system in New Hampshire it's been that
way for a very very long time that two
tiered system of Corrections that we
have uh We've in the past when we've
tried to legislate reimbursement from
the state it was always found
inexpedient uh the state didn't want to
pay for it um and so they said with
their their argument then was well we
are paying for it we're using the
property tax to pay for it and that's
our policy and that's what would
happened that's what happened in past
years when we tried to try to get
reimbursed for time spent by State
prohibition violators and county
jails thank you so we're absorbing the
cost either way either they sit in jail
at you know $90 a day or they come out
day thank you um and just so I um it
hurts my brain the the state judge
orders somebody who's on probation for a
state charge with where for example they
may have a suspended sentence in state
prison the the probation officer
violates them pending the hearing which
now is up to 72 hours they're sitting on
the County's dime after the hearing the
judge may say oh I'm not going to invoke
the suspended sentence since straford
county has such a great pre-trial
program I'm going to sentence you to
community um supervision
for whatever the 60 90 days I don't know
how often that how long they would send
them for and once again that's on the
County's time is that a correct
statement thank you however however I I
point those people who are incarcerated
in County Jail spent up to one year in
most cases in 99% of the
cases some will get released uh within
eight months for good
behavior now we've had have in the past
monitored people post trial post
conviction um so for instance they've
been good in jail but we're not quite
sure they've got a settled home life we
don't want them reoffending so we'll
monitor them for a period of time when
they're released so that's the flip side
of the argument in terms of we don't
want them coming back because most of
the time when they reoffend they'll be
in the county jail system again so it's
cheaper for us to monitor them uh post
conviction in some cases so that's
another thing you got to be thinking
about as well so if again we're talking
about State time if if someone gets out
off of a state bid early because of good
behavior and they've got four months
left um that could be reinvoke or sent
back during those four months the county
will monitor them to make sure that they
don't end up back in the county system
because that's where the next charge
will start is that if there's a new
charge if it's an old charge they'll sit
with us until they have a hearing then
most likely they would go back to State
Prison but there has been some cases I
mean we've had cross count
issues uh Rockingham has sent us a bunch
of folks uh because they didn't have the
judge wanted them to have the the type
of programming that straford had and so
we would take them um because Rockingham
didn't provide it that particular type
of programming that the judge was
looking for for that particular
individual so that's has happened in the
past um and we we voluntarily done it
because we like you don't have an
agreement with the county between
counties we just we have just a you know
gentleman's agreement that we would do
it and sometimes they'll take somebody
that we have that uh might be some
trouble for us doesn't happen too often
but we have that reciprocity between
counties where we would move prisoners
back and forth I guess that would that
that's um that's between you all right
right but that what I'm interested in is
the state county interaction and and
especially if we're talking or
contemplating expanding these type of
programs Statewide um if it's already
cost in the
county based on what state judges are
ordering how much more will that cost um
so that's good that should figure into
the numbers that we're thinking about
any further questions from the
committee oh represent Stone thank you
uh one of the questions I have is under
a straightup uh pre-trial bail
supervision situation what are the
realistic time frames in your experience
does it take from you detecting a
violation or breach of bail conditions
to filing paperwork with the court to
actually get that individual before a
judge for a
hearing so in straford county that can
happen in a matter of days we can get
someone in front of the judge in a
matter of days we have an agreement with
our judge that um and with our court
system that they can get that handled
fairly quickly you know commissioner
mcis mentioned earlier our judges love
having the tools that they have in
straford County they they don't want to
be up on that bench sending everyone to
jail or prison they want options and so
when we provide them with options
they're they're just so grateful to be
sitting in the counties that have these
programs um if I could encourage one
thing and if you're moving forward and
thinking about this I would I would
almost think about the money piece as
almost like an RFP a set of standard
conditions that these programs need to
meet in order to get the funding because
there are a lot of people that try to
run pre-trial
programs willy-nilly and they're not
doing anything standardized or
evidence-based practice or
scientifically studied and they're
making bail decisions presenting them to
judges based on their own feelings or
like a couple of questions on a piece of
paper so I really think you know there
needs to be some sort of um
accountability into that
piece thank
you um
if I could just a couple more questions
um regarding bail specifically so um if
you
could does your program offer
um the bail Commissioners more options
when they are faced with somebody at
3:00 in the morning um to make a
decision on whether or not that person
who may not probably should walk free
just with nobody looking after them
versus that or just ordering
incarceration or them beh held
absolutely we definitely get referrals
from the bail Commissioners um you know
someone 3:00 in the morning that been
arrested and they have a job and they're
saying that they have to be at that that
job in order to you know to pay for
their child's care or to keep a mortgage
or something like that they we get
referrals from um bail Commissioners for
those types of situations all the time
and so part of the the bail commissioner
will set conditions of bail and is it is
it specific or do they just say reports
of pre trial and and based on your
intake you'll decide what it is they
need or do they say monitor or stay away
from the victim and you monitor them
could you explain that a little bit yep
they'll they depending on the case they
will set um specific conditions no
contact order um report by have a curfew
drug testing electronic monitoring
equipment um a lot of that a lot of that
is changed once someone gets in front of
a judge um but they definitely use those
tools and we were putting equipment on
people every day and taking equipment
off people every day based on what the
judge is
recommending in your relationship with
your county bail Commissioners um they
they all are aware of the services you
provide um versus other B Commissioners
have in other counties may not have
these resources to use yeah we've had
meetings um with through through members
of the AOC they've come down and we've
had bail commissioner meetings and
lunchin and brown bags to talk about the
resources that are available um the
other one of the other things that
commissioner mcis brought up is very
important is the INF infrastructure a
lot of counties will say we're going to
start a drug court we're going to start
a pre-trial program but there's no
infrastructure to backfill so for
someone to be on a GPS bracelet let's
say it's $5.88 a day well we have a
sliding scale uh fee scale that we work
from but we know that not everyone can
pay $588 c a day to be on equipment so
we have a work program where people can
show up every day work a job this type
this year it's time of year it's cutting
wood so they'll work in the Woodyard and
cut firewood that we then sell to make
money in the community and then that
that pays for their equipment so to
think ahead about the infrastructure and
you know if the judge is going to order
someone to be held pending a mental
health evaluation does that jail have
someone that's going to be completing
that mental health evaluation because
that person's going to sit until they
get that evaluation then they come out
Community Corrections or someone
violates and the judge says well this is
your second chance you're going to sit
now until you go inpatient well you
better have connections and
collaborations in the community with
treatment facilities to get people into
programs quickly or it's really just not
going to work which raises another
question um so you're you're when
someone comes in as part of your
assessment you kind of look at their
their whole state of play um do they
have Medicare are they eligible for
Medicare do you help them them get
signed up for that do they have a
driver's license or identification if
they don't do you get them that do you
get them the things they need to be able
to continue being successful until
they're until they're either um finished
with their case or wrapped up absolutely
no it's a very good point um usually
after the second meeting everyone's got
a Medicaid identification number that
when they're released their Medicaid is
active um we do job we help people with
Job searches um we give people rides to
job interviews we help people obtain
their non-d driver's ID uh people's most
people don't have you know their social
security cards things that we take for
granted we help them with money
management opening a check-in account
like the the basic things that some of
us take for granted every day those are
things that we're doing in our case
management sessions with
them do you have a significant number of
unhoused individuals that you deal with
and do you help people with housing who
don't have it how do you how do you deal
with that that's a good question we do
um we have a transitional housing
program in straford county that um we
triage uh County people first so if
someone's in jail because they first of
all we're not keeping someone in jail
because they don't have housing anymore
that's changed so um they have a tent
site uh you can come in and charge your
equipment when you are you know we'll
give you bus tickets to come in and
charge your equipment um but we also
have transitional housing where
someone's if they really need a
residence and they want to come and live
at housing they can live at our housing
for free for up to 90 days and then the
expectation is that you're going to have
a job and you're going to pay a third of
that income to us to live there and
you're going to be drug tested and you
have a curfew and you're going to
participate in re-entry planning and the
whole nine yards so that's kind of like
a halfway house type of thing where
they're still supervised but they they
have a a place to live and it's they can
leave if they choose to but correct
correct okay and even all these Services
you provide you're still seeing a cost
savings oh yes versus um per day
incarceration um and I assume in
figuring into that you're talking about
the cost of Corrections Officers and
feeding and medical care and all these
buildings yeah one other quick point if
I may Mr chairman is that in under the
old system which is kind of what we've
got we've got remnants of the old system
here before we did pre-trial
assessment when a Bill Bonds would come
in
or uh when they would come in they would
ask the officer do you know about this
person the police officer arrests
somebody they're running you know IMC
report or ncic background check and
sometimes there'd be nothing in the
system so then the bail bondsman you
know he makes you know the he makes a a
judgment based on what he's heard from
the police officer you mean the bail
commissioner bail Commissioners right I
call them we used to have Bail Bonds but
we got rid of them but
um the assessment tool is is important
because because it gives the
judge uh an idea what's going on with
this person's life the old system the
judge was just sit there and say okay
it's 500 bucks or it's a th000 bucks or
it's $250 he was just making a a
guesstimate as to what the person was
able to pay or not pay based on what he
heard that
morning without any other assessment you
don't know whether the person's mentally
ill you don't know any of these things
whether they're drug adct you don't know
any of those things so with the
pre-trial assessment tool this is why
the judges like it so much because we're
an
independent Authority that's looking at
these people and making specific
recommendations to the judges as to how
they ought to be treated as we move
through the process of
adjudication uh and that's an important
thing that the judges need because the
old system it's just not a great system
and it and it basically it discriminated
against the poor for lack of a better
term it's just it is what it is I'll
probably get in trouble for saying that
but it did it discriminated against
against poor folks who didn't have the
three or four or 500 bucks and they
would just sit in jail like I told you
they'd sit in jail sometimes for 60 90
days before they'd had the hearing the
judge would come in and he'd say okay
time served you know see you later
goodbye and that happened all the time
under the in the old system and probably
still does happen in some of the other
areas don't have other resources and all
that's at the expense of the county
taxpayer correct yeah okay further
questions from the
committee seeing none uh thank you
s I know that you're not do you have a
comment turn on your microphone and
speak only to your uh only your what you
know in your county where you
are in my county in my jurisdiction
where I say it you're talking about this
old system that just doesn't exist if I
if someone is held the judge sees them
next day they're still held I'm we are
that's just not the way there's no 6090
days that just doesn't exist in
Rockingham County yeah but the question
I have
is
this I'm looking at this pre-trial
assessment and I I want to know the
profile of the person that's going to be
that you're going to be involved with as
a bail commissioner after I judge Flight
Risk and um uh danger to society do I
have the right to ask them these
questions once they're who is is this
voluntary is this for people who are
misusing drugs this isn't for my or
ordinary bail I I'm going to ask him
what his health insurance is he could
tell bail commissioner questions these
are for pre-trial Services if the is
this
optional Services is it 100% it's
optional oh yeah people people turn down
these assessments all the
time in that case wonderful and I if I
may throw in the comment I really was
appreciative of your post
trial monitoring because not because it
saves money why I understand money is
important but it sounds like it's the
right thing to do that's my my focus of
course the question thank you for
listening thank you and just for
clarification if someone's ordered for
pre-trial
services and they refuse to take this
you just tell the judge they refused
correct because the judge will say
Newman I just have a quick question
about the services that you said bus bus
things and people take taking them to
committees uh to appointments and stuff
like that are are those people
volunteers are the employees that do
that are they part of this whole
pre-trial they are employees okay thank
you
yeah representative Harry
gather thank you Mr chair um several
years ago right before coid I think
nashille was looking into doing
something similar to this um I was was
in a meeting with judge Coburn and I
think you were there because you look
very familiar and you talked about um
what was happening in statford County um
do you know if we ever implemented
anything in
nsha I know that they have some sort of
a program but I don't know that a lot
came out of that specific meeting
unfortunately I know we have mental
health and um drug courts but this
particular program we were looking at
too back then thank you like I said I
think the committee would really like to
see all the components that are part of
your your services and what you offer
and provide um one last question oh and
uh representative gather has a followup
sorry um so do you have like data how
how successful this is still out there
um with your program so our failure to
appear rate is 99.2% in
great thank
you have you done any research to see
how you bump up against the other
counties in the state no I'd like to see
what that is okay thank you um seeing no
further questions thank you so much for
sharing and um I would definitely like
more information I'd like to talk to you
about how this uh how this could work
you Ken is going to print them all um
just for the benef of the committee
representative rhs wants to say
something so committee members I just
want you to know that chesher County
where I represent obviously does have
pre-trial programs we have several of
them and I did
just I did just get a copy of the pages
of the expenses for the pre-child
programs and uh Karen is going to print
that off so we can all have a look at
that and I'm also trying to get somebody
from the county to come testify tomorrow
but you guys are going to see on top of
the the
program most of the expense is hiring
the person to do it because you're
paying State retirement you're you know
you're you're you're paying everything
that goes in along with that but there
are grants that our county has also help
offset some of these so as soon as Karen
prints them off a lot of the questions
you guys have asked will be in this for
you have they done a cost analysis
versus incarceration if there's Savings
in chest
I'm certain that they have but I don't
have the answer to it right now but I
can find out for you it comes up during
budget
discussions and now we will hear from
one more person from the is is Marat
County I believe yes thank
do
good afternoon thank you for having us
my name is Cara Wyman I'm the Human
Services director for Mar County started
my career 26 years ago working in the
court system and as a bail commissioner
um and then I worked moved on to the
Department of Corrections and served
there for 20 years leaving there as the
assistant
superintendent um and today I am the
Human Services director which brings me
to why I'm here which is pre free trial
services and adult diversion Juvenile
Diversion navigation programs and all
the programs that are outlined in the
packet that you just received from us
with me here is Benjamin Forge he is our
program manager and he supervises the
grouping of individuals who supervise
pre- child services and adult diversion
teams so as you can imagine Mart county
is different than straford County and
different than Rockingham County and
different than chachar and every other
County just all the counties are just
different so we run things the way that
we believe works for Mart County um we
also work closely with our judges and
our public defenders office and our
prosecutor's office some of the changes
that we made when I came on to pre-trial
Services two years ago um was removing
pre-trial Services out from under the
supervision of the county attorney's
office prior to 2021 in April the
prosecutor's office supervised and drove
the mindset of pre-trial services and
adult diversion and um it was my
assessment and my opinion along with the
County Administrator we spoke to the
board and we are now a separate entity
it provides us with some neutrality um
and we are able to supervise it in arms
length we're not then seen as anyone's
rubber stamp and that was important for
us um also our pre-trial officers are
not deputies they were deputized for a
time they are no longer deputized they
do not have the power of arrest um they
work as a certified correctional officer
they go through the association of
counties Correctional Academy so they
can detain individuals that are breach
of their
bail um as as straford County does we
interview five days a week Monday
through Friday I have an officer right
now it's program manager Forge goes into
the jail every morning um on average we
we're interviewing about 37 people a
month um we go in you know Tuesday it
was 11 people that he interviewed today
it was one so it varies based upon
what's happening but that is directly
related to who is brought into the
correctional facility if they get PR
bailed for an arraignment date at a
later time then sometimes we have a
Walkin from the
courts um we have 160 or9 individuals
that we're we've got supervision of this
morning
um that is approximately 70% of them are
doing exactly what they're supposed to
be doing and that one3 is 30% is not
doing what they're supposed to be doing
the way that the system works in marac
county is we report to prosecution and
defense that someone is in violation of
their bail
and that is where our arm ends it's up
to the prosecutor to file a violation
with the court um um but the judge
doesn't see a violation of bail unless
that uh we do have electronic monitoring
we do have alcohol monitoring um
straford called it Bart we we've changed
to a different system we've partnered
with our Correctional Facility so that
we can piggyback on the services which
is they are open 24 hours a day 7 days a
week and we are not so the jail and pre-
utilize the exact same monitoring system
and they they um monitor the monitoring
system for us if there's a problem they
call one of one of the individuals
that's on call through pre-trial and
then we reach out to the
client we also use an evidence-based
validated risk assessment system what
the system we use is called oras it's
the Ohio risk assessment system um it is
they we G we calculate we gather
information um from an individual in
when we interview them to decide it's
they we're deciding what their risk is
right to society um and we're working to
mitigate Risk by identifying their needs
and addressing their needs while they're
out there so if they need food resources
if they need a job if they're struggling
with substance misuse if they're
struggling with mental health my staff
is working to connect them with all of
those programs now if it's beyond if
it's a little bit more than just
accountability and holding somebody
accountable then we transfer we retain
the accountability portion of the case
but we transfer the they need help with
Medicaid paperwork or whatever we
transfer that to our Navigator program
all of our Navigators all of our
pre-trial officers all of our diversion
we're all on the same team so we we'll
sometimes simultaneously open separate
cases
so have um have you also realized the
same um cost benefit versus
incarceration in your county that um
statford did certainly I the in my
capacity as the assistant superintendent
I know that at least two years ago the
the numbers were were around $200 a day
for an incarcerated individual in Mart
County um it's around $10 a day to have
somebody um being supervised by pre-
Services because they're a free citizen
they're out in the community and our
hope is that they're being a productive
member of society they've got a job and
we're pushing on them to get that um so
they're they're contributing to society
so it's it's a cost Savings in many ways
medical is the number one cost
savings and as um you I asked them and I
think you just touched on it you you
make sure that they're coordinated um
with if they if they're entitled to
Medicare that they get signed up for it
those type of things all of those things
yes sir we even have a closet in our
basement of our building that's got
shirts and ties so if you come to court
and the judge says get out go it
happened to us a couple weeks ago go see
Miss Wiman you need a tie for court we
we dress them nicely and send them back
to the courthouse um prepared for court
so we're we're trying to again we're
we're trying to mitigate Risk by
addressing
need and um what about um helping them
obtain employment what do you do there
absolutely we we the staff will when
they when they have the opportunity to
do that if it becomes a case where the
person's a little bit more difficult um
they need more resources they need more
time spent with them we will we will ask
one of our County Navigators to spend
some time with them to help them Garner
employment oftentimes it's because
they're in recovery and they're
struggling a little bit or they're
struggling with mental health issues or
both and the Navigator is that is their
job is to case manage with somebody my
pre-trial staff is really focused on
accountability
um and making sure they make it to court
and they follow the the rules that the
court has set
down do you keep track of Statistics um
for example failes failures to appear
like we heard from um from St U marac
excuse me
straford that is a number that I cannot
give to you today but it is something
that I can try and get for you so when I
took over it in two years ago there were
no statistics at all um the county Mart
county has um worked to purchase a
program called North Point uh where the
Department of Corrections pre-trial all
the Human Services programs will all be
on the same database so we'll be able to
Garner information and it's going to
save us time and I suspect that I'll be
able to extract that type of information
what I have now is nothing more than a
fancy Excel spreadsheet anecdotally are
you seeing better um fewer failures to
appear uh fewer bench warrants in your
county based on your services uh if you
can if you do have no idea that's okay
too do you want to speak to that do you
know the
information anecdotally yes um overall
you know our rates of success are better
with with you know when we're
supervising somebody we're having a look
at who they are uh figuring out what
their needs are you know and addressing
those those needs again and mitigating
risk and and risk isn't you know
necessarily when we say risk it's not
about you know risk to Public Safety
it's risk of non-appearance or or
non-compliance with their bail
conditions which which leads to other
things so um yeah overall I would say
yes the success is more um with regard
to mental health and substance abuse um
issues do do you have um how do you how
do you deal with that you refer them to
certain places do do you have um a list
of places with available beds to put
that needs to to go for um
rehab that's probably one of the hardest
things that we do um in my entire career
I never would have bet you 26 years ago
that I would have seen the mental health
needs surpass the drug the substance use
disorders and it has it officially has
this year when we gathered the
information um we have contracted with
uh an individual who comes in and she's
embedded in our building she has her off
and know her own office and she's in our
systems um to provide um lad mlak
services to our to our clients if they
need it but that's a taxpayer dollar
that's paying for that because we cannot
get our clients into anywhere to get an
mlak assessment or to get some sort of
substance use assessment or mental
health assessment so knowing that that
was an issue for us we elected to bring
somebody in and we pay for that is that
because the those Services just aren't
out there is it because they don't
accept Medicare what is it it's both
it's both and we're seeing we're a
couple weeks ago we had a a behavioral
health uh group that just shuted their
doors on a Friday morning and they were
and they could no longer afford to keep
going um and that was a combination of
they're not getting the funding they
need from Medicare um you know our
clients don't have Medicare we're trying
to get them into Medicare and all those
types of things so it it's really it's
really a struggle to get people um the
services that they need how long does it
take you to get somebody um into
Medicare let's say they come in they
have no health insurance but they
clearly qualify for Medicare how long
does it take for you to actually get it
so that they can use it to get some of
these Services um so we do it and the
jail does it um simultaneously and it's
it's really not a difficult process to
to initiate the paperwork and to submit
it and then it's just it's hurry up and
wait like anything else you're waiting
for the process to turn back to you um
but it can be done in a matter of days
where the return if the return is done
quickly it's it's fairly fairly uh
seamless is the county able to build
Medicare for any of the services you
provide that are related to mental
health that is something that we are
actually exploring today we we discussed
what those numbers would look like um I
our diversion staff is licensed um each
of them is so we would be able to bill
for their time so it is it's a possible
Revenue Point yes
sir any questions from the committee
members representative
Stone thank you I'm going to ask you the
same question in regards to pre-trial
services do you do dual supervision with
the probation department and parole
department we do and I don't know if you
saw me shaking my head and smiling when
you asked the question because it is a
bone of contention between our some of
our staff and that the fact that they're
supervising somebody who's already on
probation parole but the reality is is
that probation parole doesn't have the
capacity to do the work that we do our
case loads are much smaller and so yes
we do double dip and they're paying the
state to supervise them and probation
parole and we're paying the County
Employees to supervise them on bail for
that violation of
probation thank you yes so the defendant
or is paying a probation fee to the
state true but you you're really the
ones doing the supervision because they
have a pending new charge is that
correct I would say that we're we work
together pretty well we do collaborate I
don't want to sh put any shade on
probation parole um but we we do the
line and share of the supervision yes
and pre pre-trial services in marac
county today does not require a fee we
do not make people pay except they pay
for their electronic monitoring or their
alcohol monitoring they do pay for that
County taxpayers do not not pay for that
but otherwise County taxpayers are
paying for pre-trial what is the cost of
electronic monitoring per day for your
county um it's $33 a week for us we do
it by week um for electronic monitoring
and it's $30 for um alcohol monitoring
so about 9% of our supervised population
are on electronic monitoring that's the
highest level of supervision we we hold
and does the county own the devices or
do you lease them how does that work
work that the cost of that we work with
a group called track group and they they
they send us the equipment and we have a
contract with them so we get so many for
free and then we pay a fee per day for
them sitting on the shelf if they're
there's not an ankle inside of them um
but this system is um it's a pretty it's
a pretty standardized system it works
really really well um and all of our
staff know how to put myself included
know how to put that bracelet on and
deploy the bracelet so we can do it
within hours of an order from a judge we
do have a process that we go about
though because you do need to have a
place to charge that bracelet so we work
out where the person's living you know
we have to get Logistics in place do you
have um a lot of clients who don't have
a place to charge or live we do and what
do you do with them and how do you how
do you provide services for them if you
can so we're lucky that we're
right up the street right on North Main
Street in conquered so we're really
close to the friendly kitchen we're
really close to all the services and we
work very closely with the Coalition de
homelessness and the friendly kitchen
team to provide services together um a
big piece of this social service process
Human Services is that if you overlap
you're choking an already choked system
it's the same with criminal justice if
we overlap we're we're putting more
effort into one person than is is
probably Fair um so we provide the
services in all the same ways
um I know that you I can send somebody
to the Market Basket parking lot and
they can plug into the light pole
because there's a there's an outlet
there and they can charge their their um
bracelet there if they have to but some
of the things that we've done is just
made sure that they know they can come
to us um they can get clothing they can
get some quick food if they need it they
can have a place to charge their devices
in our office it's a safe place it also
gives us an opportunity to lay eyes on
the person and make sure that they're in
a healthy
way do you see a large portion of your
clients um ordered by the judge to your
services how how was your relationship
with the Judiciary um I know that we
heard from the other County that they
were pleased that those Services were
offered within their County um do you
have the similar experience we have a
wonderful relationship with the justices
in marac County both in Superior Court
and in the district courts the largest
struggle we have is that they don't have
enough judges sometimes so if they have
a traveling judge from a different
County they don't know that our
pre-trial Services exist but we often
will we have we also have two courts
that are dual County courts and so that
becomes a struggle too because a judge
is in bellnap county or excuse me in
Franklin District Court is not used to
the fact that there's a there's a robust
program in Marram County because he
knows there's not one in beln not
necessarily or as just an example um but
we do have a good relationship with our
judges they are happy with our services
um and we you know a large piece of what
we do is because we've had conversations
what do you need what your honor what
are what are your needs and we tailor
our programs to that and is it safe to
say because your program exists that a
large portion of these people are able
to continue working and contributing to
society versus otherwise they would have
to just sit in your county blck up they
if they weren't out with us contributing
then you would double the capacity of
the Department of Corrections and the
price per day would go
up last call for
questions represent Stone again thank
you Mr chair as I asked the other folks
from uh straford County when you have a
violation in pre-trial how long does it
take you to get that individual before
the judge we report our violations to
the prosecutor's office and they can
elect to send it to a judge or not so
they have the discretion not to send it
if they choose to typically what do you
see in your experience if they do decide
to have a court hearing if they do
decide to have a court hearing um and
they file the motion we usually see a
hearing within 10
days thank
you representative
Pratt how early do you get involved with
the individuals I mean from the time of
the bail bond the bail commission sees
them what time do you get involved um we
get involved when the court assigns them
to us it's court ordered the baill bail
Commissioners in marac County um while
they are familiar with pre-trial and
diversion they do
not use that use that and I think it's
probably because they don't feel like
they can I and that's an that's just me
saying it I don't have the data to
support that have you reached out to any
of to try and have a lunch and learn
that the your service is available to
them um no sir we haven't we've we've
been to the brown bags are offered by
the courts but that is certainly
something I already wrote down that
Carrie said that she's done that and I
think it's a solid idea and I think that
that's something that we could certainly
do thank
you see see no further questions uh
thank you guys so much for coming in
today and providing with this
information if there's anything else
you'd like to share feel free to give it
um send it on to the
committee oh representative cro no thank
you Mr chair um I just wanted to know is
it's specific to like firsttime
offenders ERS or anyone free trial
Services is any offender okay um
diversion we have some groupings that
are firsttime offenders but the reality
is is that we're going to accept a
client we we we are all about Second
time and that will conclude our hearings
for today um I'd like to thank everyone
who came today to testify and share this
information with us once more we have a
lot to think about um we will be back
again tomorrow morning at 10:00 we're
going to be hearing hopefully from
cheshier and a few other folks tomorrow
shouldn't go quite as long I don't think
and um then next week I think is going
to be the last week of uh T hearing from
anybody and then we're going to sit down
and write write this thing thank you all
morning
big
like